we have to replace the media i don't
even think it's just the news media we
have to replace
we've got to replace the hollywood media
we've got to replace
all aspects of the media i was
heartbroken i was heartbroken the other
day because i thought
there are so few good guys in hollywood
forget conservatives i just mean guys
who are kind of balanced or kind of
normal
who aren't constantly prattering on
about politics when all i want to do is
watch them in the movie or watch them in
the tv show
and chris rock not chris rock the rock
different rocks
the rock broke my heart chris rock
actually didn't break my heart he's
still pretty funny
but the rock dwayne the rock johnson
broke my heart
the rock came out he was kind of a
moderate republican he's now he came out
and endorsed
joe biden and that's not even my big
problem with him
the rock said that when joe biden won
he hasn't won yet but when joe biden won
when the media decided to call it for
biden
the rock cried uh i wanted to shoot this
yesterday
uh when the news broke but um
but i i got a little emotional
admittedly so i got a little emotional
yesterday manly tears of course i may
have cried a tear or two or ten
but they were all very manly all my
tears have made me um
but the reason why i got emotional
yesterday was
was was because of what i felt my vote
represented
and i was talking to lauren my wife we
were talking about our two little baby
girls and
and that's exactly what my vote
represented my vote represented
my little daughters my vote represented
humanity my vote represented
decency uh it represented the values and
the principles
uh of which we we teach our little girls
and my vote also for me represented
the importance of just being a good
decent human being
so nothing that he just said
means anything it's it it's as though
he went up to a platitude slot machine
and just k he put kept putting quarters
in you know he pulled it and he said
decency yeah i voted for decency and
yeah and my daughter is your daughter
whatever i guess we're all voting for
our family right isn't that
and yeah and cha-ching and cha-ching
decency
joe biden is a crooked liar
plagiarist one of the most notorious
in the country he is a complete empty
suit even if you don't like trump you're
going to say
we elected an empty suit who's a crook
whose family enriched themselves
by peddling american influence that
makes me feel so decent
my daughters are going to love that why
your daughters like crooks why your
daughters like peddling american
influence i don't i don't think your
daughters probably care about the
election at all frankly
but people always do this they exploit
their kids for the election
that's what demagogues do he cried over
this
have you cried over presidential
elections asking the men
in the audience here have you cried even
trump i loved that trump got elected i
got such a kick out of that
i didn't cry and you know i hated that
obama got elected and i really hated
they got reelected
i didn't cry drank a little bit
i didn't i cry that's very embarrassing
we want to talk about a national
embarrassment
that's a that's a national embarrassment
to go out and say this publicly
but it seems to me that what the rock is
trying to do is position himself to have
a political career i think that's why
he's taking these stands right now
i think his his calculations are pretty
cynical i think he was always a kind of
moderate republican there have always
been
there's been a little chatter that the
rock might get involved in politics
again i'm just speculating
but i suspect that does describe
or explain why he keeps coming out with
these videos and he thought he picked a
winner and maybe he did
but he is now he's gone from being a
kind of moderate centrist quiet
republican
to just parroting democratic talking
points
notably he had to hit the identity
politics he had to talk about how
wonderful it is that kamala harris
may be elected vice president because of
course
not because she's smart not because
she's ever done anything in her career
because she she is a woman
and not just a woman a woman of color
the second congratulations of course
goes to our brand new
vice president-elect kamala harris uh
the very first woman ever um to become a
vice president and certainly
the first woman of color uh to become a
vice president
as a as a man of color and as a man who
um loves and respects women uh this is
pretty special
so first of all again this little bit at
the end here sounded a little
forced it sounded like uh i don't know
like he was there was some sub texture
and as a man who loves and respects
women like i love women
i you'll never find a greater supporter
of women than me they're like why
are you defending yourself like that pal
no one's making any accusations
but then he he opens it up in this
typically
liberal way progressive way where where
it is better to be a woman than a man
and it's better to be
of color or whatever that means than
white and so he says kamala here she's
the first woman
to be elected vice president and she's
certainly the first woman of color to be
elected vice president you say hold on
you're saying she's the first woman so
obviously she would be the first woman
of color
then you make a point you say and she's
certainly the first one as if it's in
doubt as to whether we had a white woman
vice president
which i i suppose we could have had
hillary won and tim kaine became the
vice president i suppose it would have
been possible what is he referring to is
he making some kind of
snide remark about dan quayle yeah
kamala she got elected right i guess
again if if the media are to be believed
maybe she didn't get elected then you
have to take this video down
and and that's the question that he he
gets to because he's he's assuming the
narrative that they've gotten elected
and then he says what does this mean
what does this vote mean this very
hotly contested vote that's going all
the way up to the courts what does it
mean
for our nation you know what he says he
says means we're unified
we have had the biggest voter turnout
in the history of the united states and
you know that is such a big deal because
you know it tells me number one we were
unified on that day and just in terms of
everybody coming together every
everybody uh coming out to vote
uh mailing in your ballots doing
everything you possibly can exercising
the democratic right to vote which was a
beautiful thing
okay people did exercise their right to
vote maybe some cadavers
exercised that right too but the one
thing it didn't prove
is that we're unified this is a hotly
contested election
with lots of talk of irregularities and
lots of lawsuits
that even if these numbers are
completely right is one of the narrowest
elections at any level that we've ever
had in this country
that isn't unity that's division
and the left is not promoting unity
whatsoever i hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the michael knowles show be
sure to check out the full episode
linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]